80 m6 defenses down resistance assault
underway intervene immediately
hello there
happy Wednesday I'm joined by Robert
what's up and we are gonna jump back in
a game that a game a game that I want to
say you had fun with but you don't know
me yes because of some of the
progression and loot crate and the
Fiasco's was it so hot you know not it
uh you know it was let's just say that
it was on the news for a while yeah
however however I am personally
surprised at so long story short mm-hmm
there was pay2win backlash on this game
with opening crates and how it was seen
as egregious I'm going the wrong way and
so EA pulled the ability to do so to
give real-world money and to open down
we're pulled and they really save in
saying that where they're gonna spend
some time and make it better and come
back with a better plan not just for
Michael Trent transactions but
progression sure enough I'm actually a
little surprised so you know a few
people like even myself was like I will
they'll just implement Michael trim
transactions and what let the the waters
kind of calm down right yeah but to to I
think a lot of surprised that there are
currently no micro transactions at all
and they completely let's just say like
this for now
well dope if they said April they'll
come back for cosmetics only cosmetics
because right now you can't really
customize your guys we're later on
that's the plan and they've always said
that but you cannot buy any of the of
the crystals which was the currency to
buy crazy yeah you cannot at all what
they've done is they've made everything
through gameplay so you earn like a
almost like a I want to say a new kite
type of point or up I think that what
they called an upgrade point which you
can only get through game playing
performing well I would imagine and
that's how you upgrade your cards
okay and for the most part they've
Daniel you with your three epochs or was
that the other guy don't like this map
that's fine what do you want do you want
to back out to show the progression sure
all right let's do that
so yeah again it's just upgrade points
it's playing the game and that's how you
can get and also upgrade cards so what's
actually kind of interesting too though
is that like so I have everything that I
had left from playing so everything is
untouched okay
now you and I did when the game come out
just just we opened some crates about
$100 worth it wasn't you know that
satisfying the way it was kind of felt
kind of nasty but yeah so that's what I
have is like some you know some of these
cards but like everything's here so if I
were to again this is like the new
upgrade point okay so I this is what I
would have to I would have to have one
to spend on this okay and it's that's
been playing the game now just playing
the game apparently I have yet to
because we're just booted this up today
I have yet to get an upgrade point but
what's interesting is that like take for
instance a better example or like a blue
car
okay so a blue card so this is still up
one upgrade point previously okay it's
not exponential right so this would be
you could call this like a rare card
right yeah to get it to epic it's no
different from getting like an uncommon
to comment before it was like really
ramped up as far as what you needed to
question the next level yeah and those
were crafting parts it was like I don't
know I want to say it was like 24
compared to and those are hard to get
compared to like you know to to go from
again like uncommon to common yeah so
just so you guys know basically you'll
earn experience points and you'll
receive one skill point that can then be
used to unlock or upgrade the eligible
star card you like to clip as right yeah
yeah also hello to everyone in chat
sorry if I've missed some comments there
hello JM hello Allen pears we are young
even with the update the game can't be
saved I don't know I don't think the
game itself was ever as bad as people
had felt about I feel like a lot of that
anger and rage came from the
microtransactions
and I think yeah it was mainly centered
around that and not so much the game
itself cuz the game from what I know of
like you and Aaron playing like you guys
enjoyed the game but maybe not the star
card part of it and also the fact that
people could buy the star cards I guess
at that time yeah like I mean just
compared to the last game it's
definitely a step up again yeah like
looking a side of the star cards and
microtransactions and stuff like I
thought it was pretty pretty fun like
again and starfighter us all I think is
like the highlight of this game I think
this mode is so much fun
some of the shooting still feels I think
a little bland and like say me but yeah
I think in general uh I mean this game
looks awesome and sounds awesome
it sounds awesome they got it they got a
lot of you know assets to use but yeah
that's pretty cool that they gained
Palpatine do it like they came back and
like really kind of owned up I think
yeah but do you feel like it's too
little too late oh yeah I do I do feel
like it's too late I just hope that for
all the rest of the EA games I come out
you know the next titanfall right and
all those and all these other games that
they have coming out anthem even
whenever that comes out even though it's
I think it's been delayed like I want
them to learn from this experience like
you realize how much backlash they got
from the microtransactions and really
dial it back I know that
microtransactions
will always be a thing like I think it's
just a reality now and it doesn't yeah
there's the way I do it
yeah and anyone that doesn't believe
that their reality
just on crazy pills I feel like but
there are definitely a way to do it in a
way not to do it and I've always been in
the school and you can hate me if you
want to but I've always been in the
school of like if it's just cosmetics
and it and it doesn't affect the
gameplay at all and it doesn't give
anyone an advantage I could care less if
you want to go spend the money to look
different look cool go for it if you
don't and you just want to play the game
great you know like I think that's just
the best way to approach it and there's
nothing wrong with like giving more
money and supporting like an awesome
game yeah like timeful - I felt it was
something I would gladly like I think
they actually did it pretty pretty
correctly because that was all cosmetics
so when they had some maybe like exp
boost e stuff right but nothing I mean
like again that's not like a huge it's
not like an advantage in the game with
titanfall today did they not am I crazy
about that one I thought there was like
a like a double xp type thing but maybe
I'm maybe I'm mistaken but either way
like as long as it doesn't affect actual
like gameplay especially in a
multiplayer game even right like you
don't want to have an advantage just
because someone spent money like that
shouldn't be the case I mean granted
even if you had full purple cards if you
have crappy game you're still going to
suck but you know if you're pretty close
in skill level then there's clear
differences of like if somebody has you
know potentially spent or just got lucky
on stuff so definitely want to try to
keep microtransactions if any -
Cosmetics yeah yeah this is your pie
your favorite mode right sure is I'm a
big fan of spaceships Oh
I remember Robin we saw the battlefield
rumors you're like please oh you World
War two yeah I think I just want to fly
a plane has that has that just been like
I don't know I don't confirmed I don't
think that has ever been actually
confirmed like people like rumor billing
it so I find out 83 another [ __ ] show
whatever I would even think before it
didn't they do that well didn't bow
field one wasn't that like their own
like whole something like in May or
something
yeah I remember that and then they had
yeah I'm pretty sure before I want to
say even earlier than that but we are
currently playing on PC right yeah yeah
yeah I agree ZT j TJ Zack Jeff I think
unfair advantage is stupid
let's shake him off whoa that was Bob
Jones wants to know so what does Rob
think of all the changes to battlefront
since launch do you still play I mean as
of today this is this is like this is
what the game should have shipped as but
I think we already said it like it's a
little too little too late I haven't
ever since I don't know when this game
actually come out November October
October yeah I definitely stopped
playing it by the end of the October for
sure maybe coming back I think I came
back once or twice to look at like crate
DLC but I didn't play more than an hour
I don't think also to go live on the
wrong account yes I did earlier though
it was only on my account carries wait
are we opening more loot boxes no Eric
Greenway or not although it wasn't Eric
green the guy that gave you this
spreadsheet yeah you want it no we're
not opening our boxes right now there's
no microtransactions until April and
apparently that's only cosmetic is what
Rob's telling me so in its whoa not just
my word yeah well I but I take your word
100% fair so just so you guys know let's
see what else is there in terms of the
update so yeah all this stuff as you had
mentioned are still mocked which is good
regarding crates specifically you'll get
these in a number of ways including
logging in every day completing the
game's various time challenges crates
will only include cosmetics items such
as emotes or poses as well as credits
then in April yay we'll watch a new
in-game store we can buy new character
customization options by spending
credits that you earn by gameplay or by
spending crystals that you can get with
real money that's again for the cosmetic
stuff as an example yeh said you'll be
able to make a Rodian resistance fighter
which wouldn't happen in the official
Star Wars Canon or a pink Darth Vader
so yeah I yeah I'm just hoping in the
future it will be fine
yeah William Aguilar says all heroes are
unlocked was that yeah yeah yeah that's
so that's another another big one is all
Hero ships and hero characters are all
unlocked Battlefront HQ says he thinks
this game is still salvageable I think I
think this is a solid salvageable as you
get yeah I think they did it like they
made right but is it too late it's kind
of too late for me I don't I don't
really yeah come back to come back to
play you probably wouldn't have played
right I would have checked it I would
have looked into it
having read that that those up they know
it's I think that's like oh wow cool
okay ooh
the Falcon it's just one of those things
where you know I tend to I tend to like
play games we want to play games that
like my personal friends are playing you
know and yeah I think this game could
have been that but like everyone was
like no yeah as mentioned it's been a
while Bob don't say five months it is
pretty long time I mean like I'm sure
that it takes some time to overhaul some
of the systems but you know really wish
the game ship this way well Rob and you
want a five plane I don't know about
that man what are you talking about I
just missing oh it's cuz I didn't have
any cards equipped oh that must have
been it look at that big mistake oh and
then were those experience point things
that you need to spend
oh no yeah no I want to like finish a
match cuz I think that's might maybe
that's the only way to get those new
upgrade
did you get yeah it's Carlos Medina says
it's a great game but yay got players
out of it if the game had been as it is
right now since the beginning everything
would be different I think so too
I think so too yeah Erick green do you
think that the ability to roll out
updates to consumer so easily via
Internet connectivity allows devs to
make more to take more liberties and
shipping less fleshed-out games I think
partially yes I think well it was it
like last year or like maybe two years
ago where we kept saying like man a lot
of these games are coming out like I'm
kind of like almost unfinished mm-hmm
with you know big day one patches or
like patches that would then come down
the road you know and I think that
because there's probably so much
pressure now to kind of get games out
sooner I'm not shocked to kind of see
that even though that's maybe not fair
to the consumer but I mean it just
depends on what it shows up as day one I
think yeah how much of the game is there
versus like how much you're waiting to
get it's kind of it's kind of well it's
kind of what's going on with like sea of
thieves right that's kind of the
discussion yeah I mean this week it's
hard to say right yeah definitely we see
it is hard to say because we're not sure
exactly what the endgame of that is but
like from what we know or what we've
seen so far it kind of seems like there
isn't that much to do unless you're
playing with friends in which case like
that's like already a motivating factor
right but it makes up game a lot funner
or more fun funner is not work
but we're gonna have a more in-depth
discussion about that hopefully by the
end of the week yeah I'm just talking
about oh my god we did get the crack in
day one which is pretty cool
yeah but they even that's something
where it's like we're talking I was like
is that cool the 10th time how often
does that happen because it it looked
neat at first but I don't know all he
does is kind of flail around right
J Murphy recently bought this game for
$20 it's really good glad you enjoy it
Gaetano Sosa says this game is amazing
hello Gorka me Sam VR Sam
RVD man says I don't think it's
salvageable they lost the opportunity on
a ton of revenue at launch and they're
not gonna gain it back now probably yeah
someone just kind of said it like it's
like what five five minutes Bob so real
progression
yeah real progression now and you're so
parent it but yeah basically as you play
you'll get the kind of experience points
of which you then use those experience
points to you know upgrade star cards
and unlock different things
don't shoot me anymore that's a good run
don't jinx it it's fine it is worth
buying the game now it is only twenty to
forty dollars and all the heroes are
unlocked multiple bug fixes no more loot
crate's progression of cards or in-game
skill points only microtransactions for
cosmetics only those from willing
Aguilar yeah I mean it is it's just as
our people's interest still there maybe
with solo coming soon
everyone will want to get on battlefront
to you know what maybe dude I feel like
somehow there hasn't been that much hype
for that movie and you know maybe that
makes sense I think there's not much
hype for the movie because they have
been showing a whole lot of it I feel
like it's gonna be one of those movies I
go in thinking like it might be okay and
it's gonna be like rogue one for me
where it NDA awesome yeah this is a
weird thing to think but oh no with the
EMP whoa I didn't yes I remember you're
like hey Eric watch this let's just just
wasting all the gameplay that you can't
Joshua says I'm watching this because I
keep bouncing between whether I should
buy this or not I want to love Star Wars
but I feel like it's past the point of
me giving it a try well I don't know
Joshua I think that at the price that
it's at now if you're interested the
game is still very solid and there's a
single player now which was okay
compared to last time yeah it was there
wasn't one before so I think it's worth
checking out if you were interested
before and I think with the progression
system the way it is it'll at least
reward you for your time playing the
game assuming you play or dive into
multiplayer so did you get any unlocks I
was looking I was looking to see that I
don't think so okay unless there's like
a way how long it takes I guess to get a
to get like an on one unlock or
something yeah I might as well just do
another round of this unique techniques
at a hated rogue one Wow okay that's
fair hey you know what Darth Vader's
ending was pretty freakin cool yeah I
remember telling her I was like oh my
God he's going here I was I was on the I
mean I'm of the minority that didn't
think the last hour was going to be is
that good you know in the minority I
don't think I think it was either you
like really loved it or you just kind of
were like lukewarm about it I was
lukewarm about last last Jedi hey that's
fine dude
Justin I can't say your last name but
Justin says I still play this is the
only game I find where I can just turn
my brain off and have fun instead of
trying to be the best in the game like
like overwatch and siege so a little bit
more of a casual competitive multiplayer
game for you to to relax through that
that makes sense
criteria nailed the spaceship combat
yeah Rob I remember that was one of the
highlights for you was just oh hell is
this was like oh that's right I got a
back turret let let him loose but can
you justify a 25 dollar purchase for
just a single-player campaign that's
only three to four hours off I think it
depends hello Dragoon if that three to
four hour experience is like meaningful
and I had fun playing it I think $25 is
fine I think that like money and time is
relative to the person and like you know
was it worth it to you is not the same
as it was worth it to me obviously like
I thought that's me too
even though you know I've died off of
that game it was still worth it to me
even though in some ways I'm kind of sad
that it doesn't have a lot of p1
functions but that's me right for some
other people like destiny to was like
absolutely wasted money for them right
or like some people that bought Monster
Hunter ended up not liking the combat
and like game oh really
so like you know a lot of people like
that I don't know a lot of people like
that but it's not an uncommon thing to
hear that they just didn't get into the
combat and they just ended up not liking
it however I will say at least there
were betas out before so you could find
out if you wanted to play that game or
not I guess but yeah but if you miss
those and then there's all this hype
around it and that's kind of unfortunate
but yeah you gotta do your research I
guess Sam rdb man says last shadow was
written poorly Bob Jones says I really
like light but I want more Snoke and
phasma about that well anything there
worth buying if you played the first one
ask Alex Nicolai I think that if you
were contemplating or holding back
buying this game when it initially
launched your best bet is probably now
it's probably not gonna get too much
better right Rob
I would assume I don't think so I need
to say that this is where you know they
they fixed whatever game was there like
there is no there is no like waiting
where I know people are saying oh let's
I'll wait till it's more soluble or
wherever this is this is pretty much the
big update I think yeah terms of that
party I mean without what like going
through it's like wiping the drawing
board yeah like I don't like this is
this is what they made you know
Strikeforce one hoping for new players
more noobs to murder ah there it is he's
been rude asking is there a dedicated
Conquest mode or will there be one
that's good that's a good I'm not sure I
don't know I wish there was like I think
battlefront one that conquests kukoba
in twitch chat a hundred percent feel
you on that comment that you made I'm
gonna try not to read it just as in case
two spoilers if someone hasn't watched
last Jedi yet although I know it I know
it I know it is I know exactly what it
is cuz you talk but you're this is this
is something that dates back to force
awakens right no it's it's it's in last
Jedi Malachi Nimmons it has to do with
Leia and it upset me very much like it
did not make sense to me like what
anyways still catching up on chat thank
you guys all for tuning in if you guys
didn't know I'm Eric that's Rob he's on
the sticks right now someone got boba
fett already we stream every day at 11
a.m. sometimes more than once but
usually at least once a day every day 11
a.m. tomorrow we're gonna have a loud to
say I guess so maybe not we're gonna
have a game tomorrow that's a co-op Sam
will be here I'm not sure who she's
partnering up with yet but she'll be
here playing a cool co-op game tomorrow
and then Friday I again I'm not sure if
I'm allowed to say what we're what we're
able to stream but we'll have a cool
game Friday promise you that and it
might start earlier than 11:00 on Friday
when I start at 10:00
I think you'll be here I think Rob will
be here with somebody yeah Ronnie will
be good yeah and then on Friday I think
we'll have a second stream because
deviljho
will be out in Monster Hunter I think
deviljho might even be out tomorrow so
but we're still going to stream in
Monster nephritis
dude I'm Darth Vader let's see how long
this
Chris a I'm not sure William Aguilar
says a new game-mode is coming similar
to classic conquest that that is
confirmed but it would be a month or two
from now you can check out his reddit
post apparently cool thank you thank you
for the information
died
I will avenge ooh what you know is this
Luke oh the rapid fire and you didn't
kill feels bad man [ __ ] you didn't want
that ship anyways no I didn't want that
who's who's out there is Vader out there
I just hear no that's just music oh
that's it thank coz he didn't believe me
when Boba Fett had his own little intro
music and I was like dude I've got you
he has music and we turned it up and he
totally had music oh time to take out on
the Falcon you guys can speculate on the
games I just can't necessarily say what
I'd all
so overall is the progression balance
that's my cue
it is now basically as you play you'll
slowly accrue experience points which
once you get enough experiences points
you can use that to then unlock you know
your next upgrade for a star card or
different unlocks later see you later
lovely when people come to the
livestream just to crap on a game they
don't like yeah welcome to the Internet
Justin I mean it's a shame but yes
what's up which mode is HPV say that
again is there a mode in this game
called HPV we're like like HPV h vb o
hero heroes vs. villains okay
that's what Carlos Medina wants isn't
destiny to getting a big update this
month yes boss brown sugar actually it's
next week and there was times where I
was contemplating do I want to show that
on a stream but I think destiny T is
pretty dead in my heart until the end in
May which I think was leaked May 8th was
like a leaked date for it I don't know
finally 66 iron
I think heroic strikes are finally
coming back maybe we'll street man maybe
I'll stream it I don't know are you
ready for this no yeah I don't know
maybe but the thing that I'm salty about
is just like there are so many six six
six six six there's so many destiny one
features and like things in that game
that didn't make it a two and it's just
mind-boggling mind-boggling SWAT Rangers
had like I said on my channel if you
don't care about Luke Fox's this game is
very good yeah well you definitely won't
have to worry about Luke watches now
compared to you know when it did
actually release oh god I'm so quick in
this game like I was going real fast
uh uh mecha robot says no way or you
mean a way out and you know Cooney um no
no I don't mean those there's no
split-screen in this game is it um I
believe yeah there's some like co-op
like against like it's kind of Arkady
against the AI oh okay
what's up km a long time to see long
time no chat I miss you too maybe we'll
play destiny to next week when there's
66 iron banner heroic strikes no neither
maybe I don't know what's up Deathwing I
we actually have a little Deathwing
statue back there it's like right right
there kind of like he near the Fall Out
Boy that you can see kind of want this
this match to end okay I'm getting a
little bored okay so what oh they want
heroes vs. villains there's two people
that want it oh yeah yeah I think we
should do it after this okay someone
else wants galactic assault after that
that's what I want
yep destiny to is dead to me right now
what the heck you're just like my chats
go nope I can't I'm in Japan next week
oh nice have fun in Japan then I'll play
by myself
oh you're hearing end of me now Bob yeah
I don't know we'll see well find out
more as it gets near or closer just
waiting till customization updated in
April says yes it would be nice if you
could create a character like a GTA or
stuff yeah chase got that dead heart
yeah that heart is somewhat that
gubelman I say stream the d2 updates as
Espada you're one of very few probably
but maybe maybe I'll do it just just to
kind of get nostalgic about it and I
would normally play on ps4 but maybe the
PS or PC version would be more fun to
actually play this it feels better but I
have more friends and progression on PS
where I don't know we'll see demo to a
3-2 glasses guy cute what I think the
destiny 2 has the potential to get
better like how destiny 1 had the
potential to get better got better and
then somehow we fell backwards after
destiny 1 destiny 2 is still bad game
until at least a September update 1 1
coming in the future that would be like
taking king-size probably I want
division to be great dude I want I'm
looking forward more to the division 2
than anything else right now but I just
have no idea when that's gonna come out
we'll find out I think was it made they
said that definitely e3 I can't remember
Thursday
I hope the division 2 is good there I'll
get into their announcement they
definitely said stay tuned to III but
who knows what they do some beforehand I
mean if not only for for like I only
want the division if just so we can go
to the dark zone and hope that we can
kill some people again ok so yeah that
was fun so what the Batman says we
should take a bath are you talking about
me
I do think this room gets hot this game
was such a disaster I don't think the
game itself was a disaster actually
raven's etchings I think the
microtransactions and all that stuff was
a disaster though
what's up fair couch potato hello Enzo
all right Jer Pass if you're going to
Kyoto
uh yeah no we're just staying mainly in
Tokyo so Battlefront 2 is on sale for
$23.99 on origin if you want to play
with the name of progressions as yellow
Sanchez thank you yells hedges and also
hello it's been a long time I still have
an upgrade point destiny 2 is dead in
the water
we'll see division 2 better not pull of
destiny - I I think that if anything
they know better right they had a chance
with division to actually compete with
destiny and they kind of dropped the
ball there they eventually made the game
a lot better which is like the current
state of the game if you haven't watched
Mike's piece on giving division a second
chance you should watch that because
they've really gone and did some big
updates but again they kind of had that
same problem battlefront 2 had which is
they kind of started off pretty strong
but then you know had some you know
exploits some bugginess some glitchyness
kind of lost the player base and then
came back and then they came back in
terms of like what they're able to add
to the game for the people still playing
the game but I don't think that brought
that many people back over except for
maybe some people that straggled off of
destiny - and we're like oh the division
actually is pretty good game so looking
forward to division 2 for sure thank you
guys all for tuning in hello sketch info
what's up Richard Perez how are you are
we gonna do cities and buildings because
we were requested to do so and then
we're probably to check out a galactic
Wars because I'm just gonna make him do
that
I think it's called galactic Wars it's
called galactic assault assault
collecting I don't call galactic wars
let's dude that sounds way cooler
okay who should I be oh you guys let's
be let's be Han Solo let's put some
cards on him okay look at that so were
those oh those the character levels okay
cool that's what those whoa how come I
can't be Yoda
yeah it's all right no so I picked them
Bo - you're totally right who looks the
most like the character dude good you
don't think that looks like Harrison
Ford I think that's the worse of them
really yeah I think Leyland Lando hey it
looks bad Lana looks pretty good
Leia Leah looks bad yeah it looks the
worst window looking swag though who
wants a la who wants a young Lando movie
huh well childish gambino you know
that's what I don't know more like
Harrison bored no goop no stop it
yeah Kyle 1:1 says Han looks good
Rob will you become a scoundrel if you
place although sure I don't know how
long we're gonna have to wait you know
we need four players it's pretty steep
so not a lot of players right now well
we'll give it another minute or two if
they if they don't then we'll just hop
into galactic assault sure that sounds
good and sorry to the folks that wanted
heroes vs. villains
this is heroes versus oh sorry yeah can
i chat
so
okay
what's the next game you were excited
for Eric ooh that's tough I was actually
looking at the game releases and they're
kind of thin for the next couple months
actually it's kind of scary I want to
know more about division 2 I really hope
it comes out this year but I don't think
it's it probably maybe early next year
it's hard to say maybe it does come out
this year it came out early I thought it
was like a false no no the first
division was like I want to say it like
q2 yeah yeah I can I could bet a dollar
on that you're right it's March good
thing I didn't bet you okay I'm over it
yeah Oh Dark Souls remastered is on the
song are you can play on the switch
switch don't you not have a switching I
don't have a switch anymore but I could
just use one from work but yeah that'll
also get remastered on other platforms
though so could always check it out but
I want to see how it plays on switch
stated state of decay - sounds good some
people are excited for that that's it
and I think May I'm excited for far cry
5 and that's soon that's next week it's
next week yeah but I like those games
that will keep me playing past sure I
don't know you know that I'm all about
that grind life living that grind life
yeah Eric you checking off far cry 5
I'm not boss brown sugar but we have a
couple of people in the office that I'm
gonna be playing so don't you fret we
will be streaming that once we can a lot
of people saying korekara 5 is what
people are looking forward to you is
that number right that one's too twitch
number for some reason the YouTube
number doesn't come through for some
reason I need loot games no no God war
yes God of War 100% that's yeah it is we
should hate there's really some people
about to try to try it out here and
they're raving about it I was watching
the combat from that and like I was like
oh this looks good
like I can't wait because it looks it
looks way less I wouldn't say that the
spammy part of it was ever bad from the
cold bottle wars but you know it was
more like an action game and this one
feels a little bit more deliberate a
little bit more I hate always comparing
things to souls or plug 1 or whatever
but it it like if you look at the combat
so we can sequence rather he did like a
block you know he swung his ax at one
guy he throws his accident other guy
there's just I don't know if that looks
cool to me I have to feel it and play it
but from the the preview that temor had
just recently put up if you guys haven't
seen that check that out two more got to
see the game play the game share his
thoughts
funny and we're gonna as Rob said to do
some more with it in the in this this
week check that out because it looks
good and I'm hopeful but we'll see I'll
have to see that's that's in a month
though that desert in a month April is
4/20 dude I'm totally gonna bail on
oh yeah lago is my crazy
that's 420 as well oh oh is it okay dang
so do we have to do two streams that day
yeah
yeah live in that lab Oh life I don't
know I'll get it but I would I'm just
definitely interested in what about
crackdown 3 I don't know if that has a
release date yet it is listed as q1 q2
but didn't that get delayed got delayed
yeah yeah a second time I believe dang
Bob Jones got the Pro God of War bundled
pre-ordered as a gift that's that's
going in yeah what's up battle technique
is it what I think it is Oh what the
hell is this to be announced battle tech
game
what's battle tech it's the mecha game
cool I like next yeah and then
extinction seems a little extreme I like
early April it's like attack on Titan
yeah basically yeah basically attack on
Titan is Modern Warfare 2 confirmed as
Dan Coppola I don't know I only heard
about the rumors about the remaster I
haven't seen it I mean like that was
like a like leak of like a glut Game
Stop or something modern warfare or the
next Cod is why don't warfare 2
remastered oh I did hear about that
I think battlefield if it's world war 2
it should be pretty cool oh really
apparently in the state of decay to
collector's edition doesn't come with a
copy of the game that happened with
sonic the sonic collectors didn't come
with the game either I think that's a
digital quote yeah
a shot hello DJ dogsy are you
this map is just so boring you just
slide it yeah what are you supposed to
do get into that yeah there's all these
D like you have to go underground I feel
like oh but this door doesn't work let's
go back up this is so what is up
titanfall that's shooting fish in a
barrel up here what's good gamer with no
life is good ooh
headshot it's from the Shadowrun guys on
this Dragon's crown pro roll D I'm with
you it really enjoyed the first one
gonna play a different class this time I
played Berserker first time cuz I'm all
I generally picked melee characters but
I think I'm gonna go try the archer this
time around she's more glassy but she
her gameplay when you get like later in
the deeper into the game is pretty sick
I never got too far but that game was
very deep there was a lot more going on
if people got through it all I really
enjoyed that game kind of curious to see
how how it looks enhanced essentially
it's phasma dodgy know the gamer says
I'm addicted to the vision and destiny
to gain places as I go from monster
hunter world or is it different style of
game thanks it's very similar dodge you
know the only thing that's different
though is like the actual like gameplay
of you know fighting monsters and how
that all works so as long as you're good
with the combat system in monster hunter
world it definitely has kind of
similarities in terms of the food crying
the end game oh no nice work the end
game of Monster Hunter gets really
grindy because you're pretty much
grinding out gems that you use to really
min/max your character and then
pretty much farming the different
monster parts to craft the armor that
you want the armor sets are similar to
the division where you get a lot of
customizability so yeah I think that if
you like the division destiny as long as
you like the gameplay in Monster Hunter
you'll enjoy monster no what are the two
guys named ask demo to accrete that's
Rob he's playing right now the plaid
shirt I'm Eric
we're both classes boys though died sick
yeah
what's my favorite food
I don't know steak mashed potatoes and
green beans nice yeah so like that would
be so like if somebody had one you know
that one of those almost like you take
questions what would your last meal be
Rob
that would be it now that'd be fried I'd
be pretty much on the same page steak
good piece of steak either natural baked
potatoes is fine and some steamed
veggies it's fine although I guess if
I'm going out I don't really need the
veggies whatever
what's up hell of a mouse you know you
know like the taste of like green beans
no green beans are so good like sautéed
green beans sautéed green beans no I
love green beans especially with like
garlic and all that stuff but like I'm
just saying if because usually people
asked like what what do you think your
last meal will be and I would assume my
last meal means that like I'm probably
gonna die after I eat this meal so I
don't why do I need vegetables at that
point let's just go meat and carbs
asking the tough questions live on
stream yeah of course don't you want to
get to know us better poop
is Rob using rock salt what
what's O&F I mean yeah aren't we all
at corn I'm not a huge fan of corn I
mean I like corn on the cob because I
think it's just fun and novel to eat
corn on the cob but I don't know corn is
not really a vegetable
what's up Jacob Winfield corn isn't a
vegetable like it's not a veg it's a
vegetable but you know what I mean like
in terms of like health and nutrition I
don't feel like it it Nets you very much
is that fair that's fair okay sorry no
you're fine
yeah tomato I wish I was just like about
to get like the tomato a fruit or
vegetable it's a fruit damn it that's
why I like that's what I thought I mean
okay guys like I learned that pretty
late harvest how's the update
I mean it's harder to tell you know I'll
tell you this much I'm I'm waiting to
see how how often you're getting these
upgrade points because so far we've done
two matches and we haven't gone one yet
okay if that takes a while that's gonna
be a little annoying a little annoying
especially especially considering that
rocketed especially considering that
like all of the crafting parts that
people will have a mounted or
accumulated those are gone oh so were
you better off like spending all those
like before today yeah so they're just
gone yeah you didn't get any like credit
or anything for it like no what what
they should what I would have liked them
to do experience so crafting parts are
essentially what these upgrade things
are yeah like if you had crafting parts
already and you can spend them but like
you said they probably should have been
converted to experience points problem
well yeah these upgrade points I know
right we didn't touch on that no you're
right I actually kind of just realized
that the but however yeah I mean
regardless regardless the previous
progression system is still in play hey
buddy the previous the the the gating of
like experience we are like you know
your your class rank or your
overall rank oh that's no it's still
there Oh still there yeah so like you
can't just like immediately cuz that was
the only gate right to like to
progression come on Kyle go do something
dude how great would it be like I don't
want to give them this idea but like
give them like a tantrum emote so you
could just start flipping out on the
battlefield real upset I see your little
feetsies well that wasn't Kyle oh my bad
does Bator kalo is out there earlier
though I'm pretty sure Kyle Lohse
granddad crafting parts isn't gone oh
well then that's no that isn't happening
parts will get skill point what are you
guys what you'll be able to see stuff
with them in the April update huh how
does that your crafting parts will be
able to be traded for experience points
in April 40 crafting points equals one
skill point okay thank you so I gotta
wait till APR converting them but
they've not converting it to April
that's that's great to know
Thank You Zachary our owner does a curry
Ryan from hi Jim don't know you're not
getting any because you're technically a
high level for your class based on the
amount of store cards you have so you
have to accumulate a crap ton of XP to
get to level 20 or so from your level 19
here that yeah kind of can you say that
again please
oh there is a raging emote on Kyle oh my
bad great I would I would just walk out
on the field and just spam that emote oh
you want me to read that again yeah what
was that okay you should not getting any
because you're technically a high level
for your class it's based on the amount
of star cards you have so you have to
accumulate a crap ton of XP right I get
to level 20 so far from level 19 which
is why it's taking you so long to get a
skill point experience yeah I heard
something about Zach what's my boy up to
I'm is that Zachary Ryan I don't know if
he'll ever tell us Oh Rob come on
i shouldnt have just walked out there
huh well sure whatever get me back in
here windows 10 new update installing
now ya gotta turn mine off do it in like
10 minutes
that would have been scary we would have
been screwed I hate how that
auto-updates thanks for that William
Aguilar forty forty craft room now you
protected him you did the right thing
you know whatever in proud I know it
because I always do it on Kyle oh nice
prime door great for an uh firm Abe's
twelve should I buy this game I think if
you're waiting to buy this game where
you were on the fence I think it's this
is probably like great almost as good as
it's gonna get in terms of like how they
changed the progression system how you
can get stars upgrade and whatnot so if
you see a good sale for it I think that
it's it's the best it's the thing to do
this is not Zachary Ryan started at this
point no that's alright I was more
curious than anything I'm still
appreciative of the information you drop
there I just figured I'd asked I like
how Ben only reacted when I said that
though are you a spy been some type of a
spy apparently PlayStation Network it's
also $20 whoa I don't know how he lived
but uh oh that's my native that Kyle oh
oh crap it's so good oh that was a
thermal imploder it's got a little bit
of a delay what's the party label my
cars are Karen's clearly you're stalking
is that still getting brought up if I
use rock salt apparently they do wheat
nameless Exige operators
all right that's it that's it Oh what
Gordon I finally has replays oh wow it's
like within within like Nvidia or like a
game I have to ask our news channel
give me my rocket launcher whoa Ark
survival is gonna be on switch yeah you
hear that I'm just catching up on
today's well digestive stuff hi how are
you guys doing hello
oh hey I have good news for you we have
comcast lines installed now one so we
can finally get off in that type well
the Wi-Fi stuff is is still being set up
with finally I think good I wish you
could pick the math in this game
how's the change it's pretty much the
same game we said it a bunch earlier but
the progression system is now tied
directly to gameplay so the only way you
can level up is by playing the game
oh god that scoreboard I came in late no
I didn't know well then you better it's
been a while and better yeah yeah I'll
probably do like one or two more Maps
and probably college team oh yeah we're
just checking out the progression system
now that it's tied to your experience
leveling up yeah yeah the
microtransactions will be back in april
but it's all cosmetic and as our good
chat compatriots have told us your
crafting parts will turn into skill
points and all that fun stuff so 40 for
one Firefox Firefox says play best man I
wish I could I don't think I can because
these are just random maps given to you
so can I have a bust
unless someone knows something Oh
players needed let's get bounced out
let's see what up spongebob so your
points hey man at least it's something
you can earn yourself with playing yeah
I don't I mean I can if we want to see
best Ben I can play against a I'm sure
yeah you know I feel that's been done
collecting assault yet but you can just
on blast okay is it just on blast is
that the whole thing I like this map
we're good now we're talking Shh Sheik
what's up Jay Jay are you doing
blast arms done
is almost done thank you for telling me
that we lost the ball
so how does it ask Phyllis I mean it's
as I think Rob had mentioned the hope
was or the wish was that it came this
way
on launch instead of how they initially
came out that's lay on them it is what
it is get flashed first yet
dan just getting up in there no no I
guess her her her her health regen I
guess I was hello what is your favorite
class I've been playing specialist whole
time so is it better after the update I
mean it depends have you been playing oh
nice
right at the end have you been playing a
bunch previously if you have then it's
probably not bad different for you
because you're probably so level but
yeah it's it's not as big with
difference but I think it'll be a bigger
difference for some people that maybe
fell off when your players
that's a good question what's the point
in the new progression system when the
majority of people already have what
they need and that's a damn I can't I
can't answer that yeah it has to be for
the newer people and also I think it's
like in a way like almost like I make
good in some ways but I I would also say
I would say this I know I have I haven't
played that a whole lot I mean I know I
wonder like if you played a lot say say
I bought the game at release and I
played it non-stop where is that person
set is he done or is is there still
plenty of stuff to unlock because member
that was a lot of a lot of the remember
remember all these weapons all took like
a lot like each one of these weapons is
like every mod I felt like had you had
to get like a hundred or 200 kills with
that weapon and you know there's
probably two dozen weapons like there is
probably a lot of stuff still to unlock
and as it mcfly just said I strongly
doubt that the majority has upgraded
every star card yeah exactly I mean
metal snake also brings up a good point
to learn new players and people who
skips because they didn't like it and
that's true I've already bring people
back yeah exactly
there's might even people that dropped
off really early because they didn't
like the microtransactions but now that
although that's what's actually answer
it would still be at a disadvantage
though right
technically they would just be able to
at least kind of upgrade their character
sooner oh look at that guy hiding in
between the racks or smart equipment
racks there I really like specialist
Phil I says honestly I'm going to
benefit tremendously from this
I really haven't played much but now I
want to play well there you go yeah
there you go
it looks really good though dude it
looks so good and the sound design how
that's ever so that's work oh you are
yeah barrel roll out of there oh no kill
assist that's not gonna go well thank
you good job yeah I don't that that's I
double zero said true buddy a screwed up
screw this up big time majority of sales
were the first few months new players
are punished yeah kind of
cuz like I said you're still gonna be
behind if there's other people playing
ready but at least like on a personal
level you'll know that you know you can
earn all this stuff
metella success also yeah I think
getting epics is a lot easier now within
your system it takes like maybe two or
three matches the game and level if you
play just that single class yeah if
you're playing the same class and also
you're like you know you you isolate the
cards to like you know three right like
you pick all right these are these are
three cards I'm gonna focus on cuz
that's my wand
like you can progress wow that's a lot
of dudes oh I was totally what you
didn't see that I did I was
that's lag yeah and I would have looked
really cool too I mean we can all agree
here that I should have shipped this way
oh you just want to get in the action
you know yeah in the fray you just got
to kind of you got it you gotta have a
little bit of a lag that's like almost
every one of my call of duty death
swearing right oh I didn't die and then
you watch the kill camera like oh right
okay I guess what I what was in the game
servers was not what I saw on my screen
but all right that's fair see you oh no
that's not good
no he got forced chokes that's not good
yeah I'm pretty sure do and he looked
like he got forced to be there I think
wow that guy's going for it oh [ __ ]
thank you to verify it does of course
joke that look like I know I can't come
just messing with you I'm baiting you to
go find out of his for ship don't don't
listen oh I thought you're asking chat
we want you wanted me to walk out there
show
it's like play on Akira it says cañedo
instead of Canada
if you watch the anime movie here you
haven't you should although it is kind
of a little weird it or gets your
brother
hello catman catman yeah five six seven
you know what else came out this week
that I totally didn't realize South
Park's DLC oh yeah I never finished the
game so that's where I kind of stopped
oh come on
where was you where was you oh we are
getting flanked Oh bout a hundred that
guy had a bounty hunter card apparently
that one's rare according to chat or
something like that
that be specific to a class a bounty
hunter card oh there it is I got that
you gave battle points an increased rate
oh is that true that's what I said I'm
betting on her card hey guys look into
this match
pretty even here you guys losing looks
like we're losing sweet Wow
yeah we're getting pushed back here
sweet
who is that worth it withered night yeah
Zack yes
changes worth picking up the game now I
mean cuz whose baby if you were like I
think we've been saying if you haven't
gotten into the game where you were wary
a bit from the beginning now is probably
taught the best time if you were curious
about the game right if you can get it
for love I think mostly we're saying 20
$25 progression is based off of like you
know your time played not so much like
you know buying crates and all that
stuff I mean there is gonna be cosmetics
coming back by in April
but yeah so what do I do Rob you want to
play one more match or you want to call
it a shoot
what time's it about twelve can we do
one more and start fire salt yeah
because that's what you love that's what
I enjoy playing
do you guys use the monkey emoji not
often and I use that emoji that often
that card stuff is just terrible yeah
yeah yeah it's not that great you know I
don't like is mmm feel like so often but
like I don't know managing those cars is
so frustrating because if you get into a
game you can't can't upgrade them you
can't do a whole lot and also so many
times I've started a match and it's like
oh great like none of my cards are on or
not the ones I wanted yeah just having
always think about them is I think is
lean art hearing what change in the
update is that the progression how do I
put this basically I'm just gonna read
as she doesn't read this news update
instead of plotting this
so but with the new update the only way
to get star cards is to standard
progression if you earn enough
experience points to gain a level for
that unit could receive one skill point
that can be used to unlock or upgrade
the eligible star card that you like to
equip regarding crates specifically
you'll get these in a number of ways
including and logging in every day
completing game gave the game's various
time challenges crates will only include
cosmetic items such as you know it's or
poses as well as credits then in April
you will launch a new in-game store
where you can buy a new character
customization options by spending
credits that you're earned by gameplay
or by spending crystals that you can buy
with real money an example is you can
make a Rodian resistant spider which is
not which wouldn't happen in official
Star Wars canon wonder they need to say
that because I'm sure they have to do
that because of Disney you're probably
right major lies exist is a complete
fiction it does not follow the you know
me I know you're a story Canon etc they
are strict on them yeah and then in
addition to all these changes he is said
he's planning to add new modes eval
front to in the future to keep things
interesting fresh probably Conquest mode
is one of those two things and as
mentioned from the chat earlier your
your if you had played before and you
have the sorry rubble is the upgrade
material again called the Kraken parts
of the note or crafting parts yeah
crafting parts you'll be able to
exchange those in April 40 for one
upgrade points well he's taking you on a
trip here the guy behind got him drangus
bet dead train guess that sounds like
Steve rule everyone said play one more
yep so here's our one more I'm Eric
dammit pelipper there isn't another
stream today there'll be one tomorrow
and then there would be two
Friday thanks for the great streams as
Alfie thank you for tuning in
oh yay for pink Darth Vader stoked on
that so that is actually a thing no it's
not okay what if it is then I will never
never watch Star Wars movie ever again
that's a lie and you know it you already
have your tickets for whatever it is
yeah whatever it is this guy's funny god
he wanted that to happen I gave it to
him sorry for yelling yeah that was
exactly wanted that so bad it faded you
in there only for you to crash
not again I got a milestone who's your
favorite Star Wars character asked
Maximus I gotta go with the Fett man
yeah Bubba Fett love a fat Jango Fett
some type of fact favorite Star Wars you
know who I like this was ig-88 you did a
cool droid you know he looks like I do
only because he was so tough and shut
out the Empire game you just would wreck
you kill you
always
gadem house aii sounds cool
you guys think ei should stop making
Star Wars games ha says Marcus they're
not the ones actually making it though
right that's nice it's just that they're
publishing games
I guess my virtue they they own the
properties of properties I guess or I
mean the right to use the properties I'm
just hoping that they learn from this
experience for all their future games
and how Mike returns how they want to
approach microtransactions and to really
try to find a way to respect the players
time I think that's the most important
thing we'll see what the next
battlefield yeah that's true I mean
that's always been somehow I don't feel
I know most people aren't I don't know
at least I haven't seen it too much like
they are never gets so upset about it
what is going on I know this man oh cool
I don't that's pretty neat made that up
this must be not that's I think it's one
of these ships is doing it but this is
whoa ah see I didn't have my star car
service so great
yeah sorry Publishing yeah I don't know
I mean they just need to change their
approach with microtransactions and I
think if they do that and get that right
they'll be okay or I'm I'm less although
the argument is that like ei is
potentially the graveyard for spending
that whoa yeah it's what's kind of neat
it's like a cool little environmental
thing GameSpot is the core gameplay
buttons ask party of none I mean Rob
enjoys this mode I know some people that
enjoyed the Galactic assault and then
the core gameplay what if you just
didn't factor in the cards and things
like that I think it's a solid
multiplayer game set in a Star Wars
world so you know yeah like I definitely
um well it's really cool yellow Sanchez
says I believe once those generators get
screwed it emits a field that messes
with you yeah it's pretty awesome
they're gonna need additional Bobby
Lewis asked to you play for tonight I've
been trying to get better at fortnight
it's actually not so easy to do so no
it's definitely not I was playing the
Blitz mode last night because that's
like a newer and they're just faster
paced games this is the storm and
whatnot comes in soon oh it's weird
the the demographic in that game it's
like there's the really good people and
then there's like the really bad and I
feel like I don't run into that many
average players so I'm either getting
smoked or I'm smoking or I'm beating I'm
beating up on people I don't know it's
just the the late-game building is where
I just good I look at the I go I will
never I never be that twitchy as first
building and I think every room I
definitely panic when someone's building
up on me yeah I don't know yeah what's
my counter here I guess shoot out their
platform I don't know right yeah like
when exactly like knowing an in addition
to laying down building materials is
like when and yeah when to like shoot
his when to build when to like yeah
there's a lot of
lot of stuff going on for sure the
objective is doing huh I guess there's a
gravity field as you have already seen
that you can fly in and out of yeah it
didn't look like something I want to get
into so they're just shooting up our
stuff we're just supposed to defend it
against bombers yeah
sir Barstow I agree cosmetic stuff tends
to be the stuff that most gamers in
general are most hollering to and I
think that's just how it should be you
know like there's so many games that
have come out either free to play or not
free to play that have only really
focused on cosmetic microtransactions
and sure people are upset about
microtransactions in general but that
tends to upset people less you know
overwatch does its path of Exile does
mean like only cosmetic as well at the
vets I'm like I don't know path of Exile
is an easier game for me to say you want
to support that game cuz for you you can
just download and play it so like buying
cosmetics actually helps them out
o of G or fortnight for me personally I
I want to say at least right now
fortnight and that's not me trying to be
a hipster trendy gamer I just think that
I enjoy
maybe it's my internet it's my 8 my ATV
where it's like I feel like with oh nice
we went on a victory nice I feel like
with fortnight I feel like there's more
stuff just going on and like the hub G
just feels like it's a slower game for
me and I really should be playing those
battle royale games I'm on console
because I I do a lot better on console
every see I'll tell you that yeah for
sure
but yeah that was cool thank you guys
all for tuning in thank you rob for
playing oh we're checking out that hot
Star Wars Battlefront to update
progression system give me a quick
rundown of what what that all is Rob can
you remember sure progressing in this
game is now tied directly to game play
so you are leveling up if you continue
to play in game experience opposed to
opening crates and getting cards there
are practically like no there are no
loot crate's really at the moment yeah
not until April that's all April where
that's going to be cosmetic as it should
have been so in essence this is what you
would have wanted from the launch of
this game is the status right now
so if you enjoy playing a little bit of
the game I think it's worth coming back
see how that how the system works for
you if you enjoy obviously we'll keep
playing yes then whatever we heard in
the in the chat that it's cheap it's
like 23 dollars through origin yeah I
think it's around 20 to 25 on console as
well but yeah that was just our quick
update on the update but come back
tomorrow
well obviously I'm at 11 a.m. what are
the two streams on Friday you'll see
this guy again on Friday for sure and
thank you guys all for tuning in and we
would really appreciate it if you
haven't so there hit that fall button do
that so you guys get notified
when we go live and until next time
Friday come back Friday and tomorrow and
every day every day every day at 11:00
every daar Friday might be a 10 though
later